Hãy hay miếng bố thằng sau, chuyện phủ Pakistan thùng báo đã chính thức để gử dụng
tổng thống mỹ tổ năng Trump, cho dải nuôi bàn hoặc anh hành hành hủ chậm hai
mê sau, viên nhận vào cho của ông trong lỗ lực làm giảm các thằng thằng
giữa Pakistan và nổ.
Êst là mà bá cho biết, chính sự các tiệp kýp thời của tổng thống Trump vàng
ngoại trường Mỹ Mac Coral Bio đã giúp đặt được thoa thuật lương bán vong ngày
1 mũi thần năm, ngăn chạm Wico bùng phát triển sự quy mô lớn, dựa 2
bó ra là giường, đồng sự hiểu phục hihad nhân.
Êst là mà bá trang ở tầm yên trế lực và tài năng chính trị của ông Trump,
đồng thời đánh giá đây là thời khắc quan trọng lực về phá bình khu vực.
Pakistan cũng bây to sự ủng hộ với đề xuất của tổng thống Trump về việc làm
chúng ra in cho chẳng chẳng chẳng lâu giải tại khu vực trọng mua của các mìa, cho rằng
hòa bình bình bức ớ nảm á, phủ thuộc vào việc thực thi, các nghĩ quét của hội đồng báo
á liên hợp quốc liên quan đến khu vực này.
Chuy phủ Pakistan khi bọng nỗ lực ngoại giao của Trump sẽ tiếp tục gó phần ủng đến khu vực và tỏng câu
đặc biệt trong bối cảnh căng thẳng tại giải gà ra và Iran.
Hẹn nhà trắng vạc viên đổ chưa đường dậpình loạt.
Chợp đó vào thẳng năm, tổng thống Trump đã làm chung ra thẳng hóa trắng giữa độ và Pakistan
tại Kashmir sau vụ tấn công khủng bố kể thẳng chục trụ các tình mạng hội thẳng tư.